uh
okay so uh
so uh thanks every everyone for coming
for the
uh final talk from complete the i mean i
hope it's the final talk with this is
circular based i o
maybe what will happen is that the after
part three part one will come again and
then part two and then
you know maybe there is a circular
dependence between the talks but uh
what is supposed to be hopefully the
non-circular talks
about circularity-based io in the the
third lecture
uh will be by uh daniel wicks and then
daniel i know you have a hard deadline
so let's
start all right thanks uh thanks for
being flexible on time and
uh thanks to all the organizers for
organizing such a wonderful workshop
all right so this is going to be the
third part of this three-part series on
circularity-based io
and i'm going to tell you about how to
construct another approach to get this
devio via something called oblivious lw
sampling
and this is joint work with hotdog
okay so uh this approach and this talk
we're going to follow the same framework
that
giulio spoke about in the first talk in
particular we're going to construct
an intermediate object called split fhe
uh and julie already showed you that
this notion of split fh implies
i o so the focus of this story is just
constructing this split fhe
and in this talk i'm going to tell you
about an alternate approach uh that's
somewhat different from the approaches
that giulio
and roman spoke about for constructing a
split fhe
just a little note of caution so in our
paper we actually
use a different term than split of hd a
slightly different notion that we call
functional encodings
but for this talk i'm not i'm going to
ignore those differences and
call it split [ __ ] so just a quick
reminder what split fhe is
so split fhe allows us to encrypt some
input x it allows us to evaluate some
functions
over the encrypted input and derive a
ciphertext c sub f that
encrypts f of x and lastly there's a way
to give
a short opening i think julia called it
a hint which
allows you to open this one particular
ciphertext c sub f
and recover the encrypted output f of x
and here we're going to think of f of x
as a relatively long value
and we'll want the size of this opening
that lets you open f of x to be smaller
than the output size of this function so
there's some compression
going on here and the security says that
even if i give you many openings for
many different functions over the same
encrypted input
these openings reveal nothing more
beyond the outputs of all these various
functions
and you can ask for either
indistinguishability or simulation-based
security
here we're going to focus on simulation
based security and the
common reference check model okay
and so the way we're going to do this is
actually by looking
at a fully homomorphic encryption scheme
this is a small variant of the gentrista
high and waters
fully homomorphic encryption scheme we
call it the dual gsw scheme
and we'll see that this dual gsw scheme
essentially
almost gives you split fh it has all the
right syntax it has
this nice small hint that you can give
to open a long function output
the only downside is it's not secure as
a split fhe scheme
uh if you give many openings they might
reveal more than just the functional
fields
and to make it secure we need one more
tool that we call oblivious lw
sampling a very high level oblivious lw
sampling lets you create
lwe samples without knowing the
corresponding secrets
and so this is a tool that we abstract
out and we
give a standalone formal definition of
what oblivious lw sampling is
and we have a theorem that if you have
this type of oblivious lw sampling and
you combine it with
lw assumption you essentially combine it
with this dual gsw scheme
then you get a secure split fhe scheme
and that implies a secure i o
so essentially theorem says that if you
want to construct io all you need to
focus on
is constructing oblivious lw sampling at
least as long as you believe in lw
assumption
and so one nice aspect of this
abstraction
is that this notion of oblivious lw
sampling
uh maybe in contrast to other notions
that we knew before that imply io like
functional encryption or xi or things
like this this notion really seems
simpler does not involve
any kind of general computation it seems
to be a simpler primitive
it doesn't talk about computing
encrypted data in any way it doesn't
talk about computation at all
so uh so in some sense it seems like we
really reduce the problem to something
hopefully simpler
and so the main part of the talk is then
constructing this
oblivious lw sampling um and we give a
construction that uses
lwe techniques but it's a heuristic
construction we do not know how to prove
security under the lw assumption
instead we'll prove security under a new
but relatively simple to state
indistinguishability type assumption
just that two distributions
are indistinguishable from each other
and this assumption has some flavor
of circular security that i will show
you
so uh let me get uh get started with the
technical aspect of the talk so let me
start with the learning with errors
assumption i think most of you have seen
it so this is mostly just to set some
terminology and notation
so here we have a random matrix a
think of it as a tall and thin matrix
and we're going to take a random linear
combination of the columns of a so
that's a times
s for some vector s uh plus some small
error e so here e comes from some
small distribution i get a discrete
gaussian where each entry of e
is smaller than the modulus q that we're
doing this computation over
okay so this this error has small
entries and the assumption
is uh oh and uh i'm going to call uh
as plus e and lw sample with respect to
the matrix a
so in this stock we're going to think of
the matrix as fixed and uh
look at uh sort of different lw samples
with respect to same matrix a
and lw assumption says that this uh this
vector as plus e
is indistinguishable from just a random
and independent vector of a
okay and so now i'm going to tell you
about a philippine morphe encryption
scheme
based on the on this lw assumption
that's a small variant of the
gentry high water scheme i'm not going
to tell you about
uh the details of it if you know gsw
it's it's relatively easy for you to see
instead i'm going to focus on like a few
important
aspects of the scheme that you need to
know for this talk
so first the scheme has a public key and
the public key is just this matrix
a that you saw on the last slide it's
just a uniformly random matrix
and actually this talk there's no secret
key we're never going to decrypt
there's not going to be any decryption
there's a way to encrypt some value
x under the public key using some
randomness r
and this outputs a ciphertext c
and then there's a way to evaluate a
function f over the ciphertext to get
a ciphertext that encrypts f of x
and i want to say a little bit more
about the ciphertext so here i'm going
to think of a function
with m bit output where m is the same m
as the height of the matrix a
and when you homomorphically evaluate
the function f
over encrypted data you're going to get
a ciphertext c sub
f which is a vector and it has the
following form
it's uh it's an lw sample a times rf
plus ef
plus the function output f of x times q
over two
okay so essentially the homomorphic
evaluation produces an lw
sample plus the function output and the
randomness of the lw sample is
rf and ef somehow depend on everything
on x and
r and everything that went into this
computation
okay and uh furthermore there's a
efficient way if you know the randomness
of the encryption you know the value
that was encrypted and you know the
function you're evaluating
there's an efficient way to actually
compute what this value rf is
and uh what that means is that i can
actually give you the small opening
r sub f uh that lets you break apart the
ciphertext c sub f and recover f of x so
if i give you r sub f you can
subtract out a times rf from the
ciphertext cf
you get f of x times q over 2 plus the
error
and by looking at each entry and see if
it's closer to 0 or q over two you can
you can correct the error and recover f
of x
so it looks like this scheme essentially
already gives you something that's a lot
like split fhe
so is it real is this a good split fhe
scheme
let's start with the good news so the
opening size here the size of this rf or
the hint or the opening that lets you
break apart ciphertext
is just n log q and i can make n much
much smaller
the so n is the width of this matrix and
k make that much much smaller than the
height of the matrix which is m
so uh here uh the opening can be
arbitrarily smaller than the output size
of the function
i can get as large of a polynomial gap
as i want
so that's good what about security so
let's again start with the good news
so the ciphertext does hide the input
x under the lwe assumption
that that you can prove but that's not
the security we want from split fh it's
not just enough that the ciphertext size
x
we want to say that if i give you many
openings they don't reveal anything
other than f of x and unfortunately
that's bad this does not hold here
if i give you openings are sub f to
different values they might reveal more
about
x than just the output f of x
and in fact it's not just a potentially
bad thing we in fact know there's an
attack if i give you enough openings you
can at least distinguish one x from
another it's not
clear you can like always recover x
let's see if it's random but at least
you can distinguish encrypt whether it's
an encryption one x or a different x
daniel the reason for that is that rf
and ef
are not independent for for different
f's
uh the reason is that rf depends on r
and x so um um
yeah first of all they're not
independent they're you know
they're all the only there's only one
small amount of randomness in the whole
system and you're using it to create
many openings so certainly they're not
independent
um and they can depend on all of all of
x
okay so so giving out these
openings is in general not secure um
so we're going to need to fix that and
when you say we're revealing so you're
saying i should be thinking that the
problem is that this is for different
i see this for many f's uh that's right
uh
uh that's one of the problems that if
you see it for many different apps then
it's not secure
uh even for one f uh we don't have a
proof of security it's not
uh this might be problematic even for a
single function
okay um
so actually as a warm-up uh uh to follow
up on chaffey's question
let's uh see how to achieve security in
the special case where i'm going to only
give you one opening
this is just a warm up that's not good
enough for
xio or io
but it will give us some intuition about
what we need to do
and here's the idea let's just add a
random
lw sample to the ciphertext just a
random as plus e
where uh e is going to be slightly
bigger noise
that's big enough to drown out this
error e sub f
so it's going to come from a wider let's
say gaussian distribution
and i'm going to add this random lw
sample to the ciphertext
then when i uh do the homomorphic
computation i'm just going to
add this lw sample b to the output
ciphertext and essentially you can think
of it as somehow re-randomizing
the output ciphertext and then to give
you the opening
so so just the ciphertext you get out
when you do this when you add in this
value b looks like this it's just a
combination of the original w
sample plus this red lw sample that was
added in the encoding
and then to give the opening i'm just
going to open up this new cipher text by
giving you rf
plus s so that's this new secret star
okay so that's the whole idea center i'm
just using a fresh lw sample
in the ciphertext to re-randomize or
somehow blind the
opening that i'm giving you and in fact
you can prove that this is secure this
even simulation secure
uh the idea is that i can simulate the
opening without knowing anything about
the encrypted value or the randomness
that went into the encryption
the way i'll do that is i'll pick these
values s star and e star
just uniformly at random and i'm going
to program
this cipher text b to have this form a
star plus e star plus f of x
minus the ciphertext cf and you can see
that
everything if i do this everything works
out and in fact
this is the right um
uh this is the right distribution of b
except that the air is a little
different it has this e star plus e of f
but because e star drowns out
e of f e sub f it's sufficiently bigger
this is
just the right distribution
so this gives me a simulation secure
scheme for a single opening
but we we need more than that we need to
give many many openings
so how do we do that how do we go beyond
just one opening security
so maybe the first idea that you might
have is that i can just add instead of
adding one lw
sample to the to the ciphertext let me
add many of them let me add cue of them
and that way i'll get cue opening
security for some whatever cue i want
uh however many openings i want to give
out so that works but unfortunately the
ciphertext size would then grow with the
number of openings i want to give out
with
with this number q and we cannot afford
that that's not good enough
for uh for um getting ios
or xio okay so we need
the size of the ciphertext to be
independent essentially independent of q
another idea you might have is i said we
can do this in the common reference
string model
and so why don't we so far we haven't
utilized the common reference string why
don't we add these
lw samples qlw samples to the common
reference string
so um the com reference string can be
structured so adding lw samples to it is
not a big deal
but the problem is that in the
construction we need to know
the secret s in the lw sample to give
the opening
and so the scheme would need to have
some trap door some additional
information about the crs in order to
create the openings and that's not
allowed we are not allowed to use any
kind of uh
we can work in the sierra's model but we
can't use any trapdoors about the crs
and the construction has to be
completely independent
of um of the of everything else we're
doing
of this why can't you use many bees but
but take
like condominium combinations they in
this way you you can compress a little
bit like uh
you know yeah so rather fine very good
question
so um so uh a linear combination
unfortunate doesn't work because here
i'm giving out the secrets
s and you know you would know the linear
combination so
uh uh you know uh there's no
unfortunately there's no security in
this case in fact you can show uh this
was like one of the first things we
tried and it's
pretty easy to see that this is insecure
daniel the the the requirement for
avoiding use of s in openings is this
again a security requirement because
functionality wise in the i o
construction the crs would be part of i
o right so
uh it's okay but yeah
yeah it would be that's right so in some
sense i
i need to i need the crs to be reusable
and so if i use some trapdoor for it in
the scheme i better make sure i can
you know it it means it's not
automatically reusable
um is it is it
necessarily a problem for this simple
solution it would be maybe there's
there there might be some construction
where you subtract the crs that could be
secure
but in general it's more dangerous you
have to like prove that this is okay
yeah okay um whereas
if you don't use any trapdoor it's
automatic that's reusable right
okay so uh so these are two simple
approaches that unfortunately fail
and uh the way we get around it is to
define
a new tool called oblivious lw sampling
that
essentially just lets you get around
this problem it lets you create
many lw samples from some small amount
of extra information and
so let me tell you on a high level uh
what we do is essentially combines
the two ideas above but getting the best
of
uh best of these two ideas so i'm going
to allow
a long crs but the crs has to be
completely independent of the matrix a
so i can't
put let's say lw samples in the crs
i'm also going to allow some small value
p
that depends on a but is small it should
be independent of q
of the number of samples i want to
generate so i can't just put a lot of lw
samples in p
i don't have the space and we're going
to think of putting this short value p
as part of the ciphertext
if you have crs and p they will
deterministically
determine a qlw samples b sub i
and we're just going to use uh the i
sample to generate the eye opening or to
blind
to to re-randomize the i function that
we want to open
okay uh um and i want to say that
from crs and p you just get these lw
samples b sub i you don't get the secret
sub i here we need to also give
s as part of the opening um so one way
to do that is you can just generate a
with a trap door
and use the trap door to recover s from
essaba from visa by and use that
to generate the opening that's a generic
way to do it the trap door
notice is associated with the short
value p but it's independent of the crs
because the cs does not depend on a
in our actual construction there also be
some randomness that goes into this
uh cr creating this value p and if you
know the randomness you'll be able to
figure out sub i
automatically so you don't need to know
the trapdoor for a
but in general you can just choose a
with a trapdoor and use that to recover
sabai
are the different sis independent
of one another
so i didn't tell you the security
property yet let me start with a
high-level
security property which is that all of
these samples together should in some
sense be as good as random
and i'm going to refine this on the next
slide and show you the secure property
but intuitively yes they should be like
random lw samples
uh in fact they should look like random
lw samples even if i give you the
openings as sub i
that's the intuition i'll make it clear
on the next slide i'll give you an
actual secure definition
okay um so uh so this is the high level
idea let me actually give you the
definition
so uh uh like i said before we're going
to consider a notion
in the sears model where the cs can be
very large depends on the number of
samples q i want to generate
and there's going to be the small value
p that depends on the matrix a
but it's small there's a sample
algorithm that's a deterministic
algorithm if you give me crs and p
it outputs qlw samples so anybody can
run this
and figure out the samples i don't need
to specify anything else to
uh to uh to specify these samples
and this is essentially what the honest
scheme will use
for security i'm going to require that
there's a simulator
and the simulator takes some qlw
samples bi head as input
these are just random lw samples that
gets as input and the goal of the
simulator
is to program the crs and this value p
in order to cause the sampler to output
the target values bi hat
so the simulator outputs p and crs
programs them in some way and the
correctness says that
when the simulator does that then the
sampler outputs the value that the
simulator try to hit
so essentially the similar can program
csnp to make the sampler output these uh
these these values that gets as input
and notice the simulator doesn't know
the si hat so he
it's not even sure that they're real lw
samples but has to cause the sampler to
output them
is the crs dependent on queue
the size of the cs can depend on queue
yeah
and it's supposed to be computationally
indistinguishable i guess this is
the crs output yes so this is the
security property
that you cannot distinguish between the
real and the simulated version
of the following tuples so if you see
the crs
you see the matrix a you see this public
value p so these are all the public
values
but in addition i'll actually open up
all the lw samples that the sampler
generates
you still cannot tell whether these were
generated from the real distribution
where crs is chosen randomly and p is
done computed this way versus the
simulated one where the simulator gets
these random
lw tuples as targets and has to program
these values
daniel how short is b uh just
independent of q
any polynomial but it shouldn't depend
on q i think we can relax that a little
but for uh
we don't need to daniel is isn't it
an overkill what you're trying like
eventually if you go back to the
previous slide
the adversary says just ei plus the the
the i don't know e-prime that will use
for encryption here it seems that even
if that doesn't assist both
all separately that the things will be
oh at least you know this part
separately then it will be okay or
something
very good point yes you're absolutely
right i do think it's overkill
and we do have some uh i'll show you
later we'll have some kind of
construction that doesn't quite achieve
this
but might be good enough but we will
have a kind of construction that
achieves this so it might be overkill
but
the good news is at least it's good
enough thank you
um good so this is the notion
actually before uh uh uh
you know so actually this notion is
even a little too strong for what we had
what we achieved we don't know how to
achieve this exactly
we're going to uh consider relaxation of
it the relaxation might still be
overkill just answer benny's questions
but at least
you know it's a relaxed overkill and so
in the relaxation i'm not going to
insist
that when the simulator programs the
csnp he can get the sampler to output
exactly
the target values bi hat that he's
trying to hit
there might be some mismatch between
them but
i'm going to insist that uh the
difference between them that the value
the sampler outputs
is includes the target value bi hat
plus some lw sample for which the
simulator knows the secret si hat
and intuitively this is good enough in
the construction that we had because
this bi hat
will blind or we re-randomize
the cipher text and this extra lw
sample for which the simulator knows a
secret won't hurt security in any way
so this will be this will this relax
version is good enough
and this will be what will uh aim to
achieve
okay any questions
good so that's a notion and so let's
talk about this notion of oblivious lw
sampling so we
proved the theorem that if you have this
notion it's essentially good enough in
the construction
uh i think maybe that's already looks
pretty simple or it's fairly clear to
you
uh if you saw when you saw the
construction so this is good enough
uh in the construction showed you before
to get split [ __ ] and then that's good
enough to go all the way to io
so cinch up to the lw assumption
oblivious lw sampling
implies i o now you might think that
maybe oblivious lw
sampling is in some sense overkill for
io is it something you can even hope to
achieve
so the good news is that there's actuals
a converse so assuming
i o uh we can actually obliviously
sample not just from the lwe
distribution
but from all distributions in a very
strong sense even much stronger than
this kind of oblivious lw definition
that i that i showed you
uh so uh uh so that shows that actually
um you know i o implies that oblivious
lw has to be possible obliviously
something has to be possible
and uh it was actually previous open
question if you
maybe oblivious lw oblivious sampling
not just lwe but in general
could be something easier maybe you can
do it without io
and so in some sense our work says not
really because it implies i o so if you
do it you'll
already be most of the way there uh at
least up to the lwe assumption
and uh so similar to what yale talked
about
yesterday you can interpret this as a
pessimist or an optimist so if you're a
pessimist you'll say
oh this really means that oblivious lw
sampling is is hard because it
implies io and i o we know to be hard uh
but
in this target i want you to be an
optimist and to say actually it means i
o is easy because
uh you know all we need to do now is
just to do oblivious lw sampling
daniel i don't know if you had a chance
since yesterday
did you figure out what sort of
the oblivious sampling would imply a
quantum algorithm and what sort of
oblivious something doesn't uh
no i i haven't i i wrote chris an email
i'm really curious about it
um um yeah sounds really fascinating uh
um but i i i haven't been able to look
so
yes yes i think somehow
we've with the quantum thing it's
somehow if you can generate this quantum
state that looks like a
as plus e but somehow generate it while
forgetting the uh the s and the uh
you know forgetting the s and the and
the e while doing it then
somehow uh this this is useful for
quantum algorithms but uh
it probably probably in particular it
needs to be statistically
and you might need to also to generate
each one of those samples
independently so it might yeah this is
definitely not statistical here
you need a computational assumption so
um so that that might be a big
difference yeah
it sounds fascinating though i'd like
you know for future work i guess
okay um so let's see where we are here
so
uh we have this theorem that oblivious
lw sampling and
the dual gsw scheme give you split fhe
and so now all we need to do
uh to get uh which then gives you ios
all we need to do to get to i o is to
instantiate
uh oblivious lw sampling and the way we
do this
actually is that we're going to use the
dual gsw scheme itself
uh to as a tool for getting oblivious lw
sampling so we use dual gsw in two
different ways
one to combine it with oblivious lw
sampling to get split fhe
but also to instantiate oblivious lw
sampling
we're just going to do it by using this
dual gsw scheme
plus some pseudo-random function
so let me start with an initial idea for
construction this is not our full
construction in fact
we'll see won't be secure but it conveys
a lot of the intuition of what goes on
in the full construction
and then we'll we'll adapt it we'll fix
it
so here's the idea we're going to create
a dual gsw encryption
of a prf key k just encrypt this prf key
via the dual gsw scheme and then
to obliviously compute lw samples we're
going to homomorphically
evaluate this function g over the
encrypted prf key
so the function g uses the prf key
to sample uh and for the i sample it's
going to call prf on
on the key k and some and and the value
the index i
it's going to use the output of pr k and
i to
sample some lw secrets sne and then it's
just going to output the lw
sample a s plus e so g
of k just computes a pseudorandom lw
sample for
every uh i it's looks like a fresh and
random independent lw sample
but uh unfortunately we're not gonna we
can't compute just g of k in the clear
because we're not k
at the key k and the clear we have it
encrypted so we're going to
homomorphically
evaluate g of k over the encrypted
prf key k and if you recall that's going
to give us a cipher text that looks like
this so it looks like some lw
sample arg plus eg this lw sample comes
from the randomness or the homomorphic
evaluation
plus the function output g of k
now if you're paying very close
attention i cheated a little bit
previously when we were doing
homomorphic evaluations we value
functions this output is 0 1 to the m
and we got the function output times q
over 2.
here i'm evaluating a function as output
is not 01 to them but zq to the m
and i don't have that q over 2 but it
turns out you can do this
uh essentially the same same ideas
um so you get uh when you homomorphic
evaluate gfk you get a ciphertext that
looks like this but gfk is itself an lw
sample
so i'm just going so what you get it
then is just the sum of two lw sample
a red lw sample that comes from the prf
output and a blue one that comes from
the
randomness of the homomorphic evaluation
and
uh you can just take this output and
call it the ith
oblivious lw sample
so unfortunately this does not satisfy
our definition
there's uh here there's no crs there's
no simulator
i don't know how to program anything to
cause these outputs to be the outputs i
want
so this will not satisfy the definition
but it might already be good enough for
the full split fhe construction
and we discuss in the paper and give
some assumption or write down an
assumption under which
this is secure doesn't look too bad but
that's not our ultimate goal we actually
do want to instantiate
the definition i showed you before so to
do that we'll need to do something just
a little bit more complicated but
essentially using
the same idea uh any questions on this
idea before i move on
okay so uh to to get uh our
uh to get the construction of oblivious
lw sampling we're going to
adapt this idea just a little bit we're
going to uh
include a crs where the crs just
consists of a bunch of random values
and z q to the m
we're going to do something very similar
as before so the pre-processed version
of this matrix a just conserve the
matrix a
and this gsw dual gsw encryption of a pr
fk
plus some additional bit beta which
we're going to set
to zero and then
to uh create these sqlw samples we're
just going to evaluate
a homomorphic evaluate the following
function so it's a slight adaptation of
the functions on the previous slide
so just like before we're going to
generate a pseudorandom lw
a s star plus e star using the output of
the prf
but we're also going to add in beta so
beta is this encrypted bit which is set
to zero in real life
i'm gonna include beta times the i
component of the crs
okay and the output of the the lw
samples are just going to be the outputs
of homomorphic evaluating these
functions g sub i
so the ith lw sample looks like this
it's just
uh some lw sample that comes from the
homomorphic evaluation plus the output
of this function gi
but uh the func output of the function
gi is just uh this
uh pseudorandom that we sample a star
plus e star because beta is zero
okay so we get an lw sample that really
looks the same as what you saw
before but now with this crs and this
extra bit beta we actually do have a
simulator
and here's the idea of the simulator so
the simulator gets these target values
bi hat that he's trying to program he's
trying to cause the sampler to
output them and he can modify the crs
and pe
and the simulator is just going to put
these values these target values bi hat
in the crs and change the flag bit beta
to one
so now when you homomorphically evaluate
this function
uh beta is now one so you actually
incorporate the
i component of the crs into the i sample
and so you get an lw sample of this form
uh in the simulated distribution now in
both cases whether the real distribution
or the simulated distribution the output
is always an lw sample that somehow
includes this
pseudorandom lw set the red pseudonym lw
sample
as star plus z star and the hope is that
that should cause these to be
indistinguishable you can't tell whether
you're in the real world where you don't
have this b-hat
or in the simulator world where uh this
bit is one and you do incorporate
the b-hat into the output
so uh that's really the construction and
the assumption is essentially just
saying that this is secure but it turns
out that uh this assumption is not too
bad to write down
it just translates to assuming that the
following two distributions are
indistinguishable so you cannot
distinguish the following two
distributions whether
beta is zero or one so these are two
distribution one with beta01 with beta1
so let me just read off this
distribution so first there's a random
matrix a
then there's a bunch of lw samples bi
hat
there's some uh encryption of a pr key k
and the bit beta that you're trying to
distinguish whether it's year on one
and if i stopped here if i didn't go any
further then this would be
indistinguishable under lwe so this
would all be good
but unfortunately i have one more term
in this uh in this distribution
and this is some openings of some of
these lw values some
sis i have to tell you what sis are
they're essentially going to be
the uh lw secrets contained
in the homomorphic evaluation of the
function you saw on the last slide
so if your homomorphic value this
function over the encrypted value over
the encrypted pftk and the bit beta
you get some lw sample and i'm just
going to set si so you get this lw
sample
this is what the led sample looks like
and i'm just going to set
si to be the opening of that lw sample
and the hope is that you can't
distinguish whether beta01
so that's the assumption and the
assumption has this uh
so i want to give you a little intuition
about why we believe uh this is secure
or why we hope it's secure
so it has this circular security flavor
and if you look at it
uh so the as i'm giving out uh includes
some pseudorandom value
si star and intuitively this as i star
i'm hoping hides any other information
heights whether
you know what this rg is and heights are
where the beta01
so it should cause somehow si to be
pseudorandom
uh but you'll and so that's the
intuition but you'll notice there's some
circularity here so somehow i want to
use the pr output
si star to say that it blinds or
it it um it hides this value rgi this
commit
this um i shouldn't say commitment
encryption randomness rg
this value rgi which depends on the
encryption randomness so i'm
somehow relying on the pr outputs to
hide the encryption randomness
but on the other hand i'm relying on the
encryption randomness
to hide or to protect the prf key which
is encrypted in the ciphertext
so uh you see there's really the
circularity uh
in this assumption
any any questions on the assumption so
so
that if you had like a vector of
switches instead of a single switch i
know that things will blow up but but
then could you prove it
without the circular security like if we
could switch
separately you know for only for the ice
query or something like this
ah um not sure
um no it's not clear that it solves the
problem right i mean yeah
yeah so um you know if you didn't
encrypt
the prftk here you encrypted some other
value but then still give gave out this
value as i where as i start was computed
using the pr
output then i could prove everything is
secure so
really the the question is you know are
you encrypting the pr
key itself or some other value that's
that's really what what's the difference
between we can prove secure and
where we need a new assumption but if i
also encrypted some other value that's
not the prf key then these uh
lw samples that you would generate
homomorphically this wouldn't be the
right opening for them
so you could sort of notice that i'm
doing something uh different
right so how crazy this assumption for q
equals one
i'm trying to see if you make it like
really compact right so q equals one
will be like constant size assumption is
it believable or
almost established good question
um i mean the good news is we know how
to keep q equals one really easily with
other ways i'm not sure if you exactly
try to do it with this technique if you
could even prove security for q equals
one
um not sure
one one thing that's nice about this
definition if i understand
is that you have maybe going to what
yeah you have tons of freedom because
you only want circular security between
uh between the lwe and any
prf the so the prf could be something
completely crazy could be
one of those things that we typically
model as a random oracle so
so unlike before where you had two very
specific uh
encryption schemes that you needed
circular security between them now
you basically are free to choose any pof
as long as there exists one of them
which has this circular security that's
good enough right
yeah absolutely that's a very good point
and uh i guess it also goes to this
point whether you make the strongest
assumption or the weakest the strongest
one you find believable the weakest one
you need
so i guess the strongest one that find
believable is uh this should work for
every prf
but we all of course only need it to
work for one so if you want to try to
attack it
you know use the silliest prf or the
best one that you can
hope to break that would already be
interesting
okay so um so that's pretty much uh uh
that's pretty much it for the technical
part of the talk i just wanted to
spend a little time comparing the three
works that you heard
um the last three talks essentially
and the constructions are uh they look
different
um uh um i think um sort of if you
if you just look at them and look at the
constructions they appear to be
they have some similar ideas but they
look quite different i think
conceptually there's actually a lot of
similarity
that is not apparent when you first look
at them so
i'm going to give you essentially a
translation table between the two
constructions or how things match up
so in our case we need this notion of
oblivious lw sampling
i think this corresponds pretty closely
to the other constructions where you
needed to obliviously
generate encryptions of small values uh
one nice aspect of our work is that we
can actually
abstract out this notion of oblivious lw
sampling as a standalone tool
have a standalone definition that
suffices
um i think in other words it's not there
was no uh standalone definition of what
oblivious encryption of small values
mean but intuitively that was
the main component you needed
um the way we do oblivious lw sampling
is we homomorphically generate a
pseudorandom lw sample so that's a very
high level what's going on i'm skipping
all the crs and
a lot of details but at a high level
that's that's the main
main tool here whereas in the other
words you are essentially
homomorphically decrypting a random
ciphertext in the crs
and homomorphic decryption or just well
decryption
uh uh is usually just uh inner product
with rounding
and inner product with rounding is
actually a good weak prf
uh we could have actually used a weak pr
instead of a prf wouldn't have made a
difference
so maybe you can actually think that
this homomorphic decryption of random
ciphertext
is not that different from
homomorphically evaluating a pseudonym
function for a particular surrender
function
and lastly in our work we needed some
circularity between the prf key
and the encryption randomness somehow
the pr key was protecting encryption
randomness and vice versa
whereas in the other works uh the
circularity came
from whether or not you have a key cycle
in the context of this
uh bigger srl uh shielded
randomness leakage security gain
so slightly different forms of
circularity
also uh if you look at the assumptions
themselves
i think both works the assumptions have
a circular security favor but the
concrete freezing of the assumption is
somewhat different so in our work
the focus was more on writing down a
fairly simple
uh assumption in terms of the core
underlying algebra
so the assumption is not interactive
just the two distribution are
distinguishable it does not involve any
general computation
whereas in the other world there's more
of a focus of putting these assumptions
a broader framework
where you can prove something without a
key cycle
security without a key cycle and then
the assumption is just that the same
type of security holds
when you do include a key cycle and
having that framework is really nice for
somehow getting a better conceptual
handle of what these assumptions are
about
i think in both cases the intuition why
we believe in circular security but
or why we think that these assumptions
are plausible but it's very hard to
prove them is that's actually a common
concept in circular security circular
security is often hard to prove it's
very hard to
to prove that even simple uh
cryptosystem satisfy simple notion of
circular security
but at the same time it often holds and
it's very hard to exploit circularity in
attacks because like to break one
component you need to bring another
component
to bring the other component you need to
bring the first one so it's somehow hard
to exploit the circularity
uh in attacks often uh i want to mention
something that already i think rahman
and
uh and julia also uh mentioned there is
though
i would say con significant conceptual
difference between the type of
circularity that we need in all these
works
and the basic circularity that's needed
for f for fully homomorphic encryption
and the conceptual difference is in
phlegomorph encryption
you can hope that the adversary can't
even tell whether there's a key cycle or
not he can't tell whether
you might need the the key cycle for
correctness let's say for correctness of
fhe but diversity can't tell if
correctness holds or not he can't
uh he might not be able to tell if the
key cycle is there and then because you
can't tell the key cycles there it
shouldn't hurt semantic security
whereas in our works it's very easy for
the adversary to tell whether the key
cycle
the circularity is is there or not
because
uh correctness requires the circularity
to be there and diversity can tell
whether correctness holds or not
so it's more like functional encryption
or you know that there's no split fpg
the address can actually see if he's
getting the right openings if
correctness holds
and therefore in in these cases you need
to assume
that the circuit security still holds
even though the address can
easily tell that there is a key cycle or
some circularity involved
in the game i think that makes these
conceptualists somewhat different
and let me just conclude by going over
one of the big ideas that maybe
encompasses all of the works that we
heard about in the past two days
and the big idea here is that
compression implies io it's not actually
even new to these works it's already
this idea has been around from previous
works so somehow if you can
um uh if you have some long function
output f of x and you can reveal f of x
in less amount of space writing down
pure bits than just writing down f of x
itself
without revealing anything else about x
that's the key
aspect of good doing io you can do that
you can get io
and um in the works you saw yesterday
uh the the talks you saw yesterday i
think one of the big
uh central components that already gives
you this type of compression
is quadratic fe uh it already gives you
compression for some functions for
quadratic functions
um it's it's nice you provably get
compression
it's it's uh uh you know you yeah uh uh
you get compression under nice
assumptions but you only get it for
extremely simple functions quadratic
functions and then many many additional
ideas like you saw in the talk yesterday
are needed to bootstrap from these
extremely simple quadratic functions
all the way up to uh functional
encryption or i o or compression for
general functions
on the other hand today we saw that
certain fhe schemes give you compression
pretty easily
for general functions uh you know let's
say dual gsw gives you compression
essentially for free i can compute this
big function and give you a short hint
that uh uh that lets you recover it
but unfortunately security is lacking we
know these schemes
as they are are insecure and then
additional ideas are needed
uh to upgrade security and i think it's
really interesting to sort of think
about compression under different
assumptions for example
if i just restrict myself to lwe i don't
know how to get any kind of non-trivial
compression for any kind of function
quadratic anything
so i think that's one of the big
challenges if you want to build provably
secure
io from lw try to just get any kind of
non-trivial compression
that would be very impressive and that's
where the challenge lies
so let me end here thank you
very much so
daniel can i ask you a question so uh
actually um uh have you thought about
like
a comparison between the assumptions
between aj lms and this like it looks
kind of
somewhat similar like an aglm is the con
the first
assumptions we had we had some nice lw
samples and then a polynomial
leaking on the errors here uh also
uh like you could think of it as like
some elderly samples and
and and some leakage on the
um like the input you are encrypting
uh but you don't exactly get that you
also get some noisy
terms but what you can also do is like
you can have a higher
slightly higher degree that's my
understanding
flavor wise are kind of similar yeah one
nice thing about this
this type of works is we're not
constrained on the computation you can
really do a lot
i valued arbitrary prfs because you know
we're not constrained to like quadratic
things and
so that makes our life a lot easier i
think
but it's very hard to compare these
assumptions like i i don't even know how
to compare
forget you know going to ajls but even
these these three words you heard about
now which seem very similar
we don't really know how to compare the
assumptions in them in any kind of a
formal way
is there a way to unify these frameworks
the first three
frameworks like give a general family of
assumptions where you can inst
like instantiate uh
like all these it's a great question for
future work so
none that i know but yeah um conceptual
seems like that there's a lot of
similarity
it would be great to like build to build
some framework of assumptions that let
you unify them and
try some let's maybe some uber
assumption that
implies all of these that would all be
extremely interesting
daniel say version of your assumption i
don't know if well
uh you you took away the slides but is a
version which
kind of you're saying this new
assumption plus lwe
is a way to maybe replace one of the
samples by random or something and get
like an assumption which implies like
one assumption that implies lwe
uh you know just rather than two
assumptions yeah i mean
sure you can um yeah and in fact in our
district
in the distribution i showed you the
assumption i showed you the
um um there were sort of
there are two distributions both of
which included lw samples and
in fact you know maybe more natural
thing would be to put random values in
one and lw and the other so
and sometimes we need held up yeah we
need lwe
for we need we need lw for our oblivious
lw sampler to be secure but in general
it's actually not clear
in particular io implies
uh oblivious sampling of everything so
you might be able to do oblivious lw
sampling without the lwp assumption
if you can build io not from lwe which
might be plausible
you could obliviously sample all
distributions with you know impact in
particular w distribution without lw
assumption holding and also i guess
related to the question about which brf
to choose
is your intuition that if it takes as
simple as possible like i don't know
some kind of prf i don't know whether
it's lw baseball but the simplest
possible prf
or should it be the messiest performer
which one
makes the assumption more believable
probably for for if you just care about
security and don't care about proofs
take the messiest one but if you want to
have hope of proving anything take the
simplest one
but so far you basically as you i mean
it seems like
pretty much for every natural paraff
it's probably true
we don't have any counter examples even
unnatural peers
you know do your worst um we don't know
but you wouldn't be surprised by like if
somebody gives like the same like
counter example of circular encryption
like some really you know if you exist
and there existed wherever this is not
secure it doesn't
kill your result but you won't be
surprised for example or i don't know
i wouldn't be mildly surprised i don't
know what i'm surprised by anymore these
days but
i would at least be mildly surprised it
does not seem easy to do that
just because you don't get any outputs
in the clear everything is sort of
uh you know yeah so it seems hard to do
that
so just to make sure that i understand
for following boss point about the
existence of a good prf
so let's so let's put like was like the
weakest version of your assumption and
let's try to negate it
what did what does it mean so it means
like it sounds like a
you know crazy world where whenever you
like correct me if i'm wrong right i
mean if this assumption does not hold
then it means that whatever prf you're
going to use
once you have this circular dependency
with lw
things are broken that that's the kind
of uh
so yeah that's the world in which io
would not exist as soon as so
that that may be even you know useful
this is the world we are living in that
you try to look at it as an assumption
that you can exploit
to get things like a great discussion
no we did not okay good question
uh daniel i had another question that's
also related to this like arbitrary prf
thing do you think there's any hope of
being able to like formalize an
idealized model for the prf in which
case
like where where you can prove your
assumption your
construction is secure like i i like the
obvious objection is that you're
actually homomorphically evaluating this
prf right but maybe there's still some
hope or maybe with a different
construction
yeah it's a good i don't know how to
formalize that right because i do need
the code of the prf to evaluate it so
it's
i don't know how to say it's an ideal
object yet i can evaluate it
homomorphically
but um
it just seems plausible it seems
plausible to me that me
maybe maybe not with this construction
maybe with a different construction
that uh it would it would be nice to
know right that's
like we don't have any results like uh
lwe plus uh random oracle would give uh
i o or something like that that would be
great right yeah that would be
that would be uh amazing so yeah i i
think the hard part for me is not
you know would be how to even well if
you just really were in an ideal model
that that'd be great but that seems very
hard to make work with
with our pro our high level approach
because we're really evaluating these
functions under homomorphism
and i don't know of any you know how to
formalize things otherwise where you
still have some ideal property but you
have the code at the same time
so what we were trying to do we're
trying to do something similar in the
first uh
and the first uh the one from eurocrypt
uh work
uh and what we're trying to do there was
to sort of try to sort of encapsulate
the primitive
and sort of instantiate this primitive
and idealize model
and then say you know if if you if you
can securely implement this primitive
then you know you can you if you have
the code of this then you
homomorphically evaluate this would give
you
sort of both some in some sense uh
use of idealized model in order to in
order to prove something
and then also you know once you once you
have this this part sort of
compartmentalized you you're using the
homomorphism on the
on the code so similar to their that's
similar to their oblivious lw sampling
implies io theorem right
daniel um
i'm not sure yeah because that's
oblivious yeah but
but even for the i mean it doesn't we we
couldn't make it work and i think
i think daniel also sort of the the
construction runs into the same obstacle
that uh we don't know how to sort of
push all of the random oracle into
something that doesn't require
homomorphism of the random oracle
we don't sure make sense i'm just saying
the result the result that you were able
to prove is similar to their
their completeness for lw sampling i
think yeah
if you idealized oblivious lw sampling
itself as a primitive like
thought about that as an oracle that you
just push a button and gives you an lw
sample then it'll be easy to prove but
something just that's that doesn't have
structure like a random oracle
um we don't know how to how to use that
in any way
typically people are happy when they can
replace the underwater with something
which is a concrete property right i
mean like correlation robustness or
things like this so in a sense you're in
a better shape than just using the under
marker you have a very concrete
property but but we need the code so
there's a difference right
like we always need code right i mean
no if you have like results in the
random oracle model don't need the code
right
so i don't know people like there are
papers who replace around the market
with something the property that you
know can be moved
without a black box access to an
orchestra so again
i think that moving to another market
for me at least this is the wrong
direction right i mean
you're already in better shape
um going back to your crs thing so you
sort of need one mask for every
evaluation
of a function right um
we need yes yes we need one lw sample
for every evaluation and the series is
as big as the number of samples we
output
is there any hope of doing things in the
one in the sense that if you could
do q plus one things with the crs of
meant for size q
does does it amount to solving the
problem essentially or
is it qualitatively weaker well
i would say that actually we said we
don't care about the size of that
we're we're good it's good enough to
have a long crs you still solve the
problem so we don't need to worry about
the size of the crs
um you could ask if it's possible to do
a small crs you won't get the simulation
based notion
because you know the simulation based
notion requires programming where else
are you going to program within the crs
but you might still get a good enough
notion for the final construction
thanks i actually need to run sorry
sorry everyone this is my time
thank you dania i'm happy to answer any
other questions if you have over email
please don't hesitate to send and i'll
be sure to respond and
let me maybe shabbat shalom yes
i think all the speakers of the session
we still have one more a ramp session
which actually yeah will be running
since i actually also have to go and i
might be able to participate but i'm not
sure my internet connection will be good
enough to
run it so uh so yeah we'll be running
the ramp session
it's one there's only one person signed
right signed up
one person signed up i uh it's still not
too late for if someone wants to even
with no slides or just talk about
something then
uh i mean yeah has a complete autonomy
and
feels so powerful i want to thank boz
for his organization and and all the
speakers but
was really good for you thank you so
much
[Applause]
i i really learned a lot and i i think
this is was really nice
uh very grateful for the speakers that
they
uh i'm very grateful for the speakers
that
um have
coordinated together so i think it
wasn't like uh
yeah it wasn't just like a collection of
uh
this joint talks but it was really
something we learned from and i think
that these videos will
will be very useful also for the people
that weren't uh weren't there so
so um yes so i think in uh
in in two years when one year when we
have the workshop on uh
obfuscation based only on the uh on lwe
maybe we'll say
okay some of the benefits came from
these discussions
so and so thanks everyone i'll still try
to join the ramp session if it happens
and
so it starts in six minutes right 4 20
here
yes 420 here uh assuming the the
organizer
the the one person that's signed up is
not yet here but
let's hope he comes up in six minutes
and otherwise
uh you can just continue and still
continue the kind of discussions that
people
have already been doing so thanks
everyone
thank you thank you boss thanks a lot
thanks boss